[Applause]
alright that quick gonna be here when
it's on sighs my real name my name is
Hans Kim my parents named me Hans cuz
they don't want kids at school to make
fun of me in private an Asian name
driven when it said like a charm it's
the right under the radar and no idea
was Asian a lot of bullies at my school
which is hard for me because I'm very
gender fluid I am a biologically male
with my boys identified me as a [ __ ]
I do not consent to this gender my
beliefs are like yeah you're book smart
but with street smart oh you're smart
away that's not measure boy incomparable
how convenient for you being a nerd I'm
waiting for a girlfriend right now and
I'm looking for a woman who is
intellectually stimulated by the mental
exercise of finding me attractive
like a woman is into puzzles holy [ __ ]
you're wearing that tonight okay I can
figure this out I used to date a
beautiful lady who was really into yoga
and choke sex I was like do you enjoy it
breathing or not the whole thing over
there millennialism oh my goodness
I am I am single I have yet to meet my
soul mate I'm beginning to think maybe
it's her fault she needs to get out more
you seem like a loser I think I could do
better
my friends let Hans know we're not to
talk to women maybe or maybe women
should learn how to listen to hearts why
don't you want to hear about the Federal
Reserve or the party come on yeah
[ __ ] complicated I was talking this
is one lady who I was like did you know
that my vagina is a 3d printer because I
can make a baby I was like that's not
even accurate your womb is the 3d
printer the vagina is the Train
[Applause]
it's not even a red good 3d printer
Libre is one thing with lots of errands
takes nine months to print the whole
time it's printing is complaining he
doesn't say I do not see any trays that
night such a loser man all right the
Breckinridge couple is back lodge was
warm White's the white race very gonna
thank you minimal and bacon
I think I'm a white pride is a great
thing but a lot of people do it
incorrectly they're always into like the
Nazis or the Confederate flag the never
into building a castle or yodeling you
don't have to be white to hate the Jews
I can do that too
I'm not a racist I'm a minority how
could I be impossible I don't even see
race I only smell it
never been in the cab before my aviation
of course in the big stereotype about
Asians as wheat dogs well one of the
many you know it's not looking so white
people with dog accurate not funny you
know people say we'd smell like dogs cuz
we eat them it's kind of sad but I
understand oh this is a chatty crowd
we're interacting tonight you guys the
late crowd this is fun this is what I
live for what you say miss misses the
kids
oh yeah cuz you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] about me
to take my career before it starts dogs
I remember my first beer is great that's
your right your freedoms
I don't eat dogs you know if people make
fun of Asians because we've dogs which I
understand can be very shocking because
in America dogs are treated like family
members but in Asia we treat our family
members like family members
this is real a little tradition we have
where instead of buying an animal we
love our grandma unless she's a baby
girl and since we throw in there every
rule I like to eat General Tso's chicken
I love that my Asian friends make fun of
me they're like dude isn't that just a
shitty Americanized version of something
authentically Asian and I'm like yeah
but some on what shower 3 is my favorite
movie
[Applause]